-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with Hillary and
Chelsea Clinton.
I don't want to miss the
opportunity to ask you
about some things in the news.
With the Dobbs decision --
-Mm.
-I think in the days after,
it seemed like -- maybe this is
the risk you put yourself at
when you take a snapshot
of a very small period of time.
It seemed like people were
saying that Democrats were
caught very flat-footed,
like they weren't expecting it.
But in the months since, it does
seem like Republicans are
scrambling, especially ones
that have won primaries
who are now trying to
back off their decision.
We have a lot of Republicans
saying it should be decided by
the states.
We have Lindsey Graham then
coming forward
and saying there should be
a federal ban.
Do you feel like this is, you
know, an opportunity, obviously
one that came at a great cost of
this decision?
But, you know, as the midterms
approach, how do you feel this
is going to, I don't know, move
voters one way or the other?
-Well, I can only say based on
what we've seen so far,
it seems to have encouraged
a huge number
of women and young people
to register to vote.
The numbers
from across the country are...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...higher than I've seen
in a very long time.
We also have three elections --
a special election in New York,
the Kansas election on the issue
of choice and abortion,
and then the congressional
election Alaska.
And in each case,
the pro-choice position won.
And I think that's a pretty good
snapshot because obviously,
it went literally
across the country.
So look, I think that the
Republicans have been scrambling
only because they can't quite
believe the blowback.
I mean, it's one thing to say
for years,
"We're going to do this,
we're going to do that,"
and people not take you
seriously because who would have
ever thought that women's rights
would be rolled back?
And that's --
-We did.
-Well, you and I did.
But that's because we take
these people at their word
because we know that they are
part of a relentless movement to
literally turn the clock back
on not just women,
but gay rights to enhance
all kinds of, you know, power
for corporations and others,
and limit individual freedom.
So, if people take seriously
what the court did,
what is happening in states, and
what Lindsey Graham just did,
which was to really
spill the beans --
"we're going to put in
a national --"
-15-week abortion ban.
-Yeah, a ban no matter what you
might do in your state, then
they should turn out and vote
and vote for people who, you
know, want to really protect
the right of people to make
their own decisions,
whatever that decision might be.
That's what
they're fighting for.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And I think, Seth, that to be
a woman right now is to be
political because politicians
have decided that they know
better what we should do
with our bodies than we do.
-Mm-hmm.
-And I think that women and,
thankfully, the men who believe
that women should have agency
over our lives and ourselves
don't want to go back to a time
where it's actually politicians
and not women and their doctors
making choices.
-Mm-hmm. Absolutely.
-Intimate choices.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I'd be remiss if I didn't ask
you about this.
I don't know if you've noticed
in the news,
but there's been an issue about
handling classified materials.
-Oh, I heard about that.
-We've had some fun here because
we can't help but find
a certain level of hypocrisy
from certain people,
including the fella who handled
this classified material,
because back in the day --
-Oh, so long ago.
-Yeah, so long ago. I don't know
if you've ever heard this.
[ Laughter ]
He thought
you should be arrested.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
And, you know, let me start
by saying
just for the history books,
do you know how many
classified documents I had?
Zero. Zero.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You know,
you can't make this up.
I mean, the lies they told,
you know, heated rhetoric,
"lock her up,"
all that nonsense,
it was totally political,
divorced from reality.
Now we have a serious problem
because if you just read,
and I don't have
any inside information,
what is being found,
nuclear information about
an ally or an adversary.
Incredibly top secret --
the kind of stuff, Seth, that
when I was Secretary of State,
when they talk about secret,
top secret, and then special
compartmentalized
and all of that, sometimes --
usually it was a man.
Usually a military officer,
would come into my office
and would have a handcuff that
was attached to a suitcase
in order to show me something
that was so secret,
he literally had to have it
tied to his hand.
And so, it was locked.
And then he would open it.
I would read it.
I would sign that I'd read it.
And he would take it back.
That's what some of those
folders on the outside say
was the kind of information
in it.
And so, I don't care what
political party you are,
but come on, cut the hypocrisy.
This is a threat
to our national security.
Somebody would actually have in
his country club storage room
his desk, his bedroom,
top secret information.
And you have to ask yourself
"Why?
What was he going to do with it?
Who was he giving it to?"
-Or "What had he already done
with it?"
-And so, let the investigation
go forward
and let's, you know,
find the facts.
Unlike those guys,
I'm not saying "lock him up."
I'm saying
let's just find the facts
and follow the evidence
wherever it goes.
-Well, I think if he --
[ Cheers and applause ]
I think if he realizes
he did something wrong,
he'll probably turn himself in
and say "lock me up."
[ Laughter ]
-Right.
-If I know the man.
[ Laughter ]
-He'd want to take
responsibility.
-He will take responsibility,
if there's one thing we know
about the man.
Hey, Chelsea,
this is very exciting.
Especially as someone with three
kids of my own, you wrote a book
inspired by having
three of yours.
-I did, I did. So, I wrote,
"Welcome to the Big Kids Club"
because when I was pregnant with
our third, Jasper,
Charlotte and Aidan
had all these questions
like, you know -- Well, first
they asked, "Is it going to be
a boy or girl?" And I said, "I
don't actually know the answer
to that because we're going to
be surprised."
But then they asked other
questions like,
"When will the baby
talk and walk?"
And "Will the baby poop,
like, on day one?"
And "Why don't babies
have teeth?"
Because it would really hurt
if you're breastfeeding.
[ Laughter ]
That's actually not the answer,
totally, but...
[ Laughter ]
So I decided to write a book
because I thought,
"Well, if we're having
these conversations, we're
probably not the only family
having these conversations."
And so, I wish I had had
this book when I was pregnant
with Jasper,
and I was so thankful to Tania
for the extraordinarily
beautiful illustrations.
And just so proud and excited
it's out in the world.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Well, it's very exciting.
Thank you both
for making the time.
It's always a pleasure...
-Thank you, Seth. Thank you.
-...to see you especially
together.
Hillary and Chelsea Clinton
everybody.
"Gutsy" is now streaming on
Apple TV+.
We'll be right back with
Kate Berlant, everyone.